alright we're live welcome everybody to
another YouTube hang out I'm super
excited to have my friend Rebecca
Coleman with me today we met at the sage
summit in New Orleans was it about a
month ago yeah I was at the end of July
end of July Wow time flies Wow not
really and Rebecca wanted to do an
interview with me about how to use
content to help you grow your following
online and I thought hey why don't we do
this is a google hangout instead of
going back and forth an email so all you
guys could learn as well so overdue you
Rebecca oh yeah so yeah it was really
cool to meet you at sage summit were
both Canadians I was quite tickled to
meet another Canadian there was really
great and so I'm from Vancouver and
you're from Toronto someone sort of
opposite ends of the country right now
but that's cool it's this is why I love
technology it's so great so the thing
that struck me about you when I met you
and this is a real trend that I'm
noticing a lot in social media today
which is that a lot of people are using
inspiration as a way to grow their
following so by inspiration I mean
they're like creating inspirational
quotes and posting them on Twitter and
Facebook and that seems to be a really
popular trend right now and it also
seems to work really well and I noticed
that so much of your brand your personal
brand is about that is about inspiring
people and that was really why I wanted
to interview you and to talk to you
about that and for us to talk about like
how can you use things like inspiration
to grow your brand and to grow your
following cool um yeah I believe more
and more that people want to know who
you are what you staying for before they
want to know about what you're selling
and I think a lot of a lot of
entrepreneurs a lot of companies when
you first start selling whatever your
product is you start off talking about
what it does the feature benefits
benefits yeah features benefits features
benefits right they start with features
and then somewhere along the line they
learn about benefits whether they read
it in the book whether they meet
somebody your default is to think about
your thinking like features technician
that's what you're doing some point you
learn about benefits and
it's what most people 99% of the world
sells that way above that the next step
in my view is what I call core selling
and it's understanding what it is that
your business your brand stands for and
letting people know that before you ever
try to sell them any product or service
and Nike does this Apple does this babe
let's do this yeah new campaign that
just came out a couple of days ago by
Kellogg's called own it have you seen it
no it's really that but I yeah nike
really does that well okay you never
seen nike talking about the features of
their shoes no instead of talking about
the benefits of their shoes no it's
about doing it just do it right they
even nice that and and and they become
you know a huge huge success Apple same
thing became the biggest company in the
world by market cap without ever talking
about the features or benefits other
than their product and so that's what
people want to know about people want to
understand what you staying for first as
a company before they care about what
your products are all about an example
another one that people may not know too
much about is the honest company there
in California it started by Jessica Alba
and Christopher gato honest yeah I do
know them yet honest yeah and so they
started a couple years ago they now have
a over billion-dollar valuation and
everything is about honest there they
took their core concept their core value
and put it into their name and so now
you know their concept is everything
that we make is made with honesty and
integrity the low carbon footprint
everything is made in the USA as much as
possible this everything is organic and
just you know that anything you buy from
the honest company is of a certain milk
and so you don't need to always look at
then the features and the benefits of it
as much because I the honest company
when I go to Whole Foods I just assume
that everything in whole foods is good
getting good breeding i right the food
the clothing the coffee everything right
and so they've done a really good job of
that core selling and
so then it's look what are you staying
for is a company for me it's believed
right I've got it on the wall here it's
it's a theme throughout all of my stuff
and I think the important thing is to
understand it's not just a marketing
thing a lot of entrees are looking at
what what what what does the market want
to hear that's something that's core to
me that's that's who I am and as a
result I hire people who love believe
you know I I do my marketing around
believe I create products and videos and
content around bully believe is a core
concept of everything that I used here
on my business not just seeing it
through the world of a marketing
strategy and so when you apply that the
content if you take that approach we
figure out what do I stand for the human
being what's the positive impact i want
to make in the world and so for me it's
believed for others it might be
something else for a salsa companies i'm
a part of their their one word is family
so everything is run through that lens
of family yeah then that can start to
one make it easier for you to create
stuff create content create products it
makes it easier for people to talk about
you and spread it and it makes you used
to build a falling around it and so my
my business model has become create a
lot of belief content kick up a ton of
noise and as a result that generates a
lot of business for me if it's speaking
if its products if it's consulting gigs
with a website and so any entrepreneur I
would HIGHLY encourage them to figure
out again what is it you staying for and
then funnel all of your content not not
so much talking about the products and
services and the benefits associated
with it but more talking about the
positive impact that you want to have on
the world and that will tie people into
your brand to want to learn more that's
some that's some pretty powerful stuff
that's really cool I think it's funny
when you say like people ask questions
like well how can I market this or
whatever like what do you mean but I
think we're savvy enough and we're smart
enough that we can tell if someone is
just doing it to sell us something or if
they really believe it you're
mean do you not feel like you can tell
like if somebody's just in it because
they're in it for the money and they're
not in it because they love it or their
passion can you not tell I think we can
tell ya people have a rbs meters going
higher and higher and higher sensitivity
is that's what is yeah and it's got to
be authentic it's got to be real and
again it's not just something that why
use for content marketing is how I run
my business when I'm hiring a programmer
for my website i will name the job add
you know believe programmer needed okay
and and then i'll talk about the mission
of the company what we're all about
before i even get to what the job is all
about i'm talking about what the
business stands for and some people will
read that and be like this is the
stupidest thing I've ever seen it's
comfortable equally I believe is so lame
come on it's great like I do not want
you you don't work with that guy it's
like dating right yeah please self
eliminate this is a magazine and then
you'll get other people who look at that
saying wow that's awesome I mean wait to
go work at that company and now I'm not
just another website that's hiring a
programmer where there's lots of options
I've set myself apart which is which is
good for some people and bad for others
but allows them to differentiate easy
and so you do the same thing in your
marketing if you're clear on what you
staying for now you're not just one
provider of shoes or dresses or
computers or whatever right ones get
through this and so it makes it easier
for me to make a decision either to go
with you or not go with you but it's a
fantastic way to start attracting more
ideal clients and on social more ideal
community members who will help you
spread your message for you right um
yeah I like that a lot I mean it's
almost like in some ways it's like when
you're hiring someone it's almost like
looking at soft skills versus hard
skills you can teach people hard skills
like if they don't know what a code you
can teach them to code but if they if
they're a jerk and they're no fun to get
along with you don't want to work with
that person do what I'm saying so in
some ways it's like you really want to
work with people who share your values
and who have that thing in common with
you
then the rest of the stuff can kind of
follow yep it's it's your team it's your
social media followers it's your
customers you know I had customers big
clients big brands who I won't say their
names but they want to do deals with me
and they're just all about the selling
like evident you please sell our
microphones to your senses that is not
like if that's what you're coming to me
for we're not going to get along yeah
and I made the mistake of trying to
teach them and trying to change them and
try to make it work and didn't work it's
it's like with any people right you
can't really change your husband or your
wife or your boyfriend or girlfriend
right accept them for who they are uh
and so like that's who those people are
and that that's not a fit for my
business yeah and and until I had until
I knew what I stood for right give me
the clarity right as I see oh this is
big deal on the table all their money
right like there's money and it's so
easy and money is a value and there's
nothing wrong with valuing money right
like we all like to have a nice place to
live and I have a thing for shoes you
know so um we all need those things
right but you know it's also money as
for me money is never enough like i
can't i have a really difficult time
working for someone just for the money
like I'm too old for that when I was
younger I could do it now it's like no
there has to be more there has to be
some kind of intrinsic value in it for
me or else I don't want to do it so
money is a byproduct of value right the
more value provides somebody the more
money you're gonna make right a lot of
money can run a lot of value a lot of
money quickly about a lot of value
quickly that's how you're gonna make a
lot of money and and then so then the
question becomes how can I provide value
because that's going to give me money
you're going to be able to provide the
most value when you're doing something
that makes you come alive when you're
passionate about right where if you
might be skilled at something but if
your heart's not into it you're gonna
drag in your feet on it your value is
not going to be off the charts you might
make enough to get by and to do the job
but it's not going to be next level we
can look at anybody who's that success
in any field not just entrepreneurs you
look at the people the top of their game
they love what they're doing it makes
them come alive and so they're providing
an insane value and when you do that
you're making a lot of money so that
this is the path to make more money
right even though it seems like you're
making money by turning down clients I
don't get it that client is never going
to be an ideal client is it your timing
it work for another client that then is
right exactly no it frees up your time
the coop durand work with more ideal
clients and it's just every time I've
tried it it's just an insane headache
and nightmare and I wish I did not take
on this deal more ulcers yay yay just
what we need is entrepreneurism work for
all sir um okay so let's talk some like
hardcore stuff now let's talk about what
so I get it that's all the kind of
theory stuff but how do you translate
this into real life are you talking
about like through a social media
contacts here in social media yeah I
think so first of all is understanding
where your audience is in where can you
provide the most value so when I when I
started in social I was all on linkedin
linkedin was my thing then i moved to
facebook that i moved the twitter and
then i moved to youtube and i'm still in
all the platforms but i'm most heavily
involved on youtube one because my
audience is there right entrepreneurs
are there in two because my you know i
love video i love video more than
writing more than any of the platforms
and so understanding where your audience
is and where you can provide the most
value if you don't like being on video
you're better writer maybe you should be
blogging may be sure Twitter you know if
you're a graphic design person or
photographer maybe you should be on
facebook and instagram if you like me on
video then maybe you should be on
youtube and so i think a lot of
entrepreneurs try to over commit to
doing everything and then just being
mediocre or worse than mediocre
basically like sucking at every platform
because they're trying to get everywhere
yeah where i would really hone in and
focus on again where my audience is and
what I'm good at and makes me come alive
then from there it's creating the
content schedule what kind of content
with
to be putting out what's our Callen
we're going to look like you have your
core value that now is being funneled
through and I create content that makes
me come alive and I feel like that is
always the best indicator uh some of the
best stuff that I post on my youtube
channel I post because like I need it
like I wish somebody else had created it
and nobody did not to you and I I made
that right like um for example I have a
series on my youtube channel called an
espresso and it's a morning series and I
always felt like man I wish I had
something every morning to just like
wake me up like punch me you know like
get me thinking bigger get me think ID
on my current environment cuz we can get
to in our habits and our limiting self
beliefs and I wanted something to make
me think bigger and I couldn't find it
there was I kept I've kept looking and
researching and there was nothing out
there so i said i need to i'm gonna
create this myself here my neck it is
it's true and so we did we created i
created it for myself I was a selfish
thing and I shared it with the world and
people loved it and so everything that I
post even if we're not talking to
YouTube world you're talking Twitter or
Facebook the stuff that I post I like
like it makes me happy the quotes that
I'm putting up resonate with me it's not
just going and searching top 10
entrepreneur quotes and doing a copy
paste of what other people have done
putting it up if i'm posting something
from Oprah or you know Steve Jobs or
whoever it is it's because it resonated
with me on some how some level made me a
better entrepreneur made me think and so
because it had that impact I'm sharing
it out and I think a lot of people don't
do that and I get it like you're
stressed you're overworked you're you're
like I wanted I gotta put something on
committer you're worried about growing
your business and for me now I have
people help me do it but with all the
research that's done all the people that
are on my team every piece of content
gets filtered through me before it goes
live it's your name on
it's my name and I guess my reputation
but more so like I want to create
content that I care about and and if I'm
if I love the content other people going
to love it too if it means something to
me is going to mean something to other
people as well and so that's the process
right we pick a platform where customers
are that that we can get involved in
that suit our skills then it's creating
a Content schedule that is encompassing
of your core value that you love and
then it's then creating individual
pieces that you feel are missing that
inspire you right they don't inspire you
they're not likely going to inspire
other people that's awesome um let me
ask you about branding your content so
what I noticed that you have a lot on
your feeds I see you know you have
quotes and stuff like that but you all
your stuff is branded do you think that
that's important or is that sort of like
a level two thing is it more important
to just get out there and start doing
some of this stuff or is it something
that you should sort of be doing from
the very beginning uh it's important but
I would put it as a level two hey I
think it definitely helps so I mean I
have you know I've got my plane logo the
name yeah oh the white yeah the plaque
away but I mean my local was like this
what used to be blue instead of black
and some of my really stuff didn't have
anything out I think I think this is
what's important I think a lot of people
make this checklist of all the things
that they have to do before they launch
something and that Nicholas grows and
grows and grows and then you never
actually do anything yeah so so they'll
say uh well I'm not going to put
anything up because i don't have the
perfect yeah branded and so Evan said
it's got to be praying so I'm not going
to put it out and that's wrong right
like get it out and then tweak and fix
and add more because especially in the
social world a lot of the stuff doesn't
live that long YouTube might be the
exception and so people forget and the
goal is not to be the goal you have
to be better than yesterday it's not to
be perfect it's me better than you were
yesterday so start getting quotes up get
better quotes up make it into a picture
put your logo on it call it a series you
know when i started the ents presso
series it's the combination of espresso
and entrepreneurs and began copy yeah
right people start the day with it so I
want people to start the day with paints
presto I didn't have a game for it
wasn't named anything it was just a
morning video that came up and then we
created a logo for then we created the
name for then we created intro for then
we created a theme song for and it's
grown to this thing but if I waited
until I had all of that if I would
haven't even launched it and so the key
is to get it up and then improve and
tweak and proven tweak yeah sometimes
you just gotta jump off the cliff right
and you know and see what happens you
know and then the other thing is just
learning from your mistakes hopefully
right like I mean that's to me whenever
people ask me what you know how you
defined being self-employed or being an
entrepreneur it's always about making
mistakes and learning from them like
that's all it is really do any mean it's
like oh wow that was an expensive
learning experience okay I'm not gonna
do that either day mean like yeah I made
this mistake early in my career my first
business I was 19 and I i had a biopic
software company and i spent an entire
summer working on this business plan and
it was the perfect business plan you
like I gotta get every detail right
everything's gonna be perfect when I get
it out like this is it we're gonna kill
it we're gonna crush it and everything I
done up to that point I had been mildly
successful i right if I don't if I
worked harder I would get more results
and then we launched it and all of our
assumptions were wrong and just started
failing hardcore and just like the
lowest part in my life and feeling like
there's nothing worse and feeling like
you are not valuable like the hard work
and love that you're put into something
is not being depressed right now and we
end up losing a 40 million dollar deal
because we were too late because I spent
too long working on my business plan
uh which sucks 22 years old right except
those yeah history of your heads up yeah
yeah yeah I think it happens a lot of
people into like that that that
perfectionist nature in me I'm still I
still like to be perfection and get like
get things done a certain way but give
up the perfect to go for the good and
then tweak and make better and so I've
always tried to do that now with all the
new stuff after learning that super
expensive mistake and hopefully for
everybody watching don't make that same
mistake that I think that's awesome well
thank you so much Evan that up I I'm I
thought that was great I I got a ton out
of that I mean we've got a bunch of
questions on the chat well uh first one
is glamazon diva piercer nice hey I do
body piercing I have low i get i get low
followers what do you think would be a
good idea that should i use instagram or
facebook how do i get more likes on my
page what do you think um I i think i
might lean towards if it was me i think
i might lean towards instagram um
instagram is really super hot right now
and you don't have to deal with stuff
like the algorithm and if you're taking
really pretty pictures and you're using
the right hash tags you probably would
be able to develop a decent following on
Instagram I know tattoos are really hot
on Instagram right now tattoo artists I
have a friend who's a tattoo artist and
he has like I don't know like he has a
lot of followers people follow him
because they really like his artwork the
challenge with instagram is that it's
not great for driving traffic to your
website it's great for developing your
brand but in terms of actually getting
traffic to your website out of it and
not so great yeah i would be i would do
two things i agree with the Instagram in
terms of like the free awareness i take
amazing pictures of what you're doing I
don't know what's so differ
about your piercing compared to other
people but if you have some great
pictures it lends itself super well to
Instagram maybe even Pinterest because
it's more of a woman demographic and you
you have diva in your name so I'm
assuming that that might be a market for
you uh facebook I would do the facebook
game right now is paid advertising yeah
totally if you want to get you want to
get traffic you want to get attention to
where is you have to pay and it works it
does work and so I would look at if you
can identify with the Facebook dark post
who is your ideal client so if you're
looking at I target women between 15 and
30 who live in British Columbia and like
you know these kinds of bands right here
things you can rantoul facebook all that
stuff right and so that's it really it's
the it's the cheapest way to go ahead
and get your pictures and content in
front of a targeted list like a hyper
targeted list and so if you are just
posted on your facebook page you're not
going to get a lot of lights but it's
not the game anymore the game is in the
paid advertising and driving people into
your shop so I'd be doing Instagram for
the broad awareness and then I'd be
doing small tests with Facebook dark out
do the budget weird america Zuckerberg
yeah small budgets and test to get
people into your salon you know what
though it like as much as people
complain about it Facebook Ads really
work like I've been doing a ton of dark
posting lately and our CPC's on those
are like less than 50 Cent's like it's
really like it's good cheap advertising
yeah I love it next Salvador I'm running
a clothing brand and my sales are kind
of low what should i do and how can i
market myself i'm doing this online I
not to like I pop the whole Instagram
thing I don't know who your target
market is or what kind of clothes you're
selling exactly but not to hype up the
whole Instagram thing but there's a ton
of fashion stuff happening on its scrum
right now it's really really hot it also
kind of depends on what your demographic
is if you're going for a younger
demographic snapshot might be an
interesting way to go
um and Pinterest if your demographic is
women because that's definitely where
they are yeah I'd also throw you tube
into the mix and I would be looking to
target youtubers who have an audience
that you're trying to reach influencers
yeah you know I get a lot of deals
working with big brands who want to
target entrepreneurs because that's my
audience but um but also like how do you
add value like instead of just taking a
pit like a really pretty picture of
something maybe show people like some
fashion tips like here's a jacket it
like and show like three different ways
of styling it or something like that do
you own a mean like how can you add
value to instead of just saying look
here's this really pretty jacket and
it's on sale or it's not or whatever but
like here's this really pretty jacket
like how do you you know it's the first
day of fall like what does the first day
of fall look like with this jacket do
you want I mean putting it in context
and adding some value yeah I would try
two outs out i mean honestly the
gameplay is partnering up with
influencers even the lower ones now who
would just do it for free right yet you
give them product the bigger ones you
have to pay them to do it which is still
the model but uh the smaller ones I
don't know what size you'd be looking at
maybe 10,000 to 50,000 subscribers
somewhere in that range yet look Holly
do it for free just if you gave them
product um you know every time I wear
what am I not the even the belief shirts
but we're one of my the custom shirts
that I make that was asked people want a
hater right and I'm not a fashion
channel so if you were targeting people
who are doing haul videos and that kind
of stuff it's an easy way especially
some kind of distinctive look or logo
feel it's more about finding out who is
that person that could be a good fit for
you and it's a great is a great example
for them use if they haven't done any
kind of partnerships before they could
use that video to then go out and get
more rights or content so you like a
leap jumping-off point for them yeah i
mean i'm on youtube I got my YouTube
blinders on
nothing you want bitter i'm all about
twitter so yeah but like for this one I
don't it's harder it's harder to win on
Twitter it's doable but a clothing brand
you have to be you have to be a lot more
intelligent it's a party the one I think
then then a visual medium agreed like
Instagram or YouTube parallel hi from
Brazil hey Paolo keep up the good work
awesome Rafael Evan I sell wholesale
products how do I start using social
media for my company I don't think
people will follow me what is your
advice should I just try it Izzy b2b is
that the issue uh I says wholesale so
yeah yeah b2b is a challenge right um
b2b is hard because you're a business
selling to a business as opposed to a
business selling to a person it's a lot
easier to make a connection with a
customer right then it is to make a
connection with another business having
said that behind the business is always
a person right so how do you make those
connections with people really you know
I mean it's like link people talk about
b2b and b2c but everything really is
person-to-person at some point at some
point someone has to sign the contract
and you have to sign the contract so
who's the person that needs to sign yoda
mean and how do you connect with them
yeah my two thoughts are any time it's
b2b I think linkedin yeah totally place
would be to be you could join I don't
know what you're selling just said
products but yeah I'd be trying to join
groups I'd be trying to reach out to
influencers whether you're doing an ad
campaign targeting people who work at
certain companies or you're just trying
to connect to them and make an email
introduction on anything b2b that's a
platform that you want to be heavily
engaged on if not investing money in 20
the other thing is that be I'd be trying
to raise awareness around my products
and so I don't again I don't know what
you're selling but if you had an
Instagram following or Twitter following
or YouTube following then it makes it
easier for you to go and do your pitch
yeah to the company right people might
ask for it right like if I'm a customer
and I know you I might go
you're selling to whole foods or you're
not selling to whole foods i might going
to whole foods and say would you please
stop this I want it right where can i
buy this right I live in Nebraska what
stores are selling it right then you can
take that information to go to stores
and Nebraska and say hey people are I
can direct customers to your store yeah
so there's still I played both angles
that use LinkedIn to get the
introductions and then build the help
help the retailer's build awareness for
the brand don't just rely on them you
want people asking about your product
yeah maybe even to the point of like
taking some really great photos of
whatever it is that your product is and
sending those photos to your sellers to
help them with their social feeds like
if you have some really great products
you can send or picture story that you
can send them and say you know here are
some pictures that you can share an
Instagram Facebook whatever help do
their job for them I guess is what I'm
saying yeah yeah I love it ah Vinnie I'm
starting a business with my clients are
only employers how can I use social
media to target my clients without
targeting the wrong people that are not
potential buyers has sorry his targets
are what employers input so should he be
on linkedin yeah I mean I think it's the
same thing as the last one if you're
selling we linkedin is the platform that
you want to be most important where
people are looking for work and people
are hiring that's where it happens yeah
I don't know what you're selling to
these employers but I am a thought
leader i'm reposting content on linkedin
and being engaged in related groups
you're building yourself a car HR
managers may be that kind of thing HR
professionals yeah join the groups that
are relevant to your industry to your
product whatever product or service
you're selling those are groups you want
to be part of um knife 23 VI how do i
pick good promoters and they don't take
my money from me oh that is an excellent
question so i just want to say for the
record i love this industry but
sometimes it's hard to be in it because
I hear a lot of stories of people who
are taken advantage of and
that's not right so I would first of all
um go to someone asked if you can get a
referral to someone that they've worked
with in the past and actually call them
and do a reference the other piece is
that what I'm finding is happening these
days is a lot of people who will like do
your social media or whatever for you or
say they'll do your social media for you
they'll do it but they don't um
necessarily report back to you so I
would ask for something like say could
you send me a ripple of a report that
you've sent to when your clients in the
past right what you want to see is
really careful data analytics and
reporting back from that person so that
you can actually see that they're doing
their job like empirically that they are
doing their job I think that's really
important yeah you know I don't think he
should I don't think you can effectively
outsourced your social media I haven't
seen a company do it really successfully
even though look at the brains that I
work with I work with some big brands
all of them are using agency I'm gonna
get in trouble no it's good you're not
getting with me you might get in trouble
with my bosses I don't think you should
have a service your solution media um
most is because they can't get the voice
right like it should be your voice
coming through as an entrepreneur this
is how you compete against the big guys
we have the established brand you don't
have a big marketing budget what you
have is your voice right your passion
why did you start this thing right why
is it what does it mean so much to you
that's what you need to be pushing out
because otherwise you're competing
against guys who can execute you in
every other category and so giving it to
some agency to do where they're not
working at your business but they don't
have your voice I think if you're going
to delegate it it should be somebody
that you hire in your company I like
your marketing person or whatever who's
gone through the process who understands
your core value right who's
because of believe or whatever you stand
for who gets it who lives and breathes
your business not some outside
consultant and I know that might upset a
lot of social media consultants but um I
don't think it's so important I don't
think you can you can outsource it
effectively and I haven't seen people do
it right the other thing that I say to
people is if you're going to hire
someone to do your social media you need
to know enough about social media to
know whether or not that person is doing
a good job right it's like hiring an
accountant great hire an accountant but
you also need to know enough about
accounting to know whether or not your
accountant is doing a good job do you
want to meet you yeah uh Damien is next
do business cards still work well I
don't know like I have a stack of them
right I was at a conference last weekend
and I have a stack of them right here
you know my plan is to go through each
one of them an email each one of these
people and follow up with them and say
hi I don't know though like Evan do you
like I make primarily gonna make my
contacts with people online these days
to be I'm like when I meet someone I'm
like follow me on Twitter you know and
then we'll be connected I don't know
what do you think I haven't used a
business card and I want to say seven
years all right then I wonder if I have
like an old ones in one sitting right
here of yours I'm buying up I got them
from mu and they have my instagrams on
the front and then on the back they just
like have my name and phone number and
email yeah I can't find mine my I a so
old I've got like a year with blond tips
on it's like wow that's an old pic it's
been a long time uh yeah I use business
cards and in I mean we were at the sage
conference together a lot of people give
me their cards that I'll collect them i
guess but yeah i don't use them I don't
like when people give it to me and much
rather they send me an email and I
happen in my gmail um I think if you're
going to use them it should be something
that stands out my business card out
you're pretty cool it stands out you
notice it look I should have it
somewhere
swallow this is very similar but that's
that's how like not important it is fun
like business card anywhere I don't know
depends on also what industry you're in
I don't know we're in a very tech heavy
industry where literally it's like Oh
follow me on Twitter and then we're
connected gionee mean like I would
rather connect with someone a linkedin
or twitter then like have their business
card which I'm probably just gonna throw
away right yeah I think or more though
it's a becoming less less relevant yeah
um next Zeno Zeno is a loyal YouTube
viewer Evan you're not a fashion
champion what are you talking about no
I'm not a fashion champion haha you're
again what's the best way to stand out
with social media there's so many people
with the same interests and sometimes
better than you are yeah um I know it's
tough it's tough out there I mean I you
know I think you gotta figure out what
it is that makes you unique and like
that's kind of what we've been talking
about all morning right like what's your
values like what is it that makes you
unique and different and for me I think
it often comes down to voice like how is
your voice even if you're talking about
the same things as other people how is
your voice different in that way like
how do you talk about it what is it that
makes you you know different right yeah
I think I think nobody can be a better
you than you yeah in that so like you
said they're not not you Rebecca but
you're gonna saying yes because they're
better than you are right so they are
better than you want some things but
you're a better you than they could ever
be and so it's understanding who are you
right where are the unique skills and
opinions and mindsets that you have you
know me I'm an entrepreneur I'm
believing other entrepreneurs I'm a Blue
Jays fan I love salsa dancing oh wait
hey YouTube were like so hey I see the
world through a lens that nobody else in
the world sees the world through and so
that's what you need to do and
understand that that's valuable I think
a lot of people think well that's not
who cares about that well people will
care like what
what's the powerful as you care right
like what do you care about what's your
powerful message how do you want to make
the world a better place that's what you
need to be pushing out through social
and see it through your eyes and if it's
something that makes you come alive when
you're excited about that'll make other
people come alive as well holy Tobias
Tobias loves cap locks the bias rights
guys this is awesome everywhere I am so
inspired caps yes Thank You Tobias
myself all caps I know you couldn't tell
i totally said that at all i was
speaking about that uh Rudy how to reach
an audience for custom designer items
like wooden clocks the stuff I make is
unique and often expensive to produce
cool and well I mean one thing that I
well one thing that I find have helps a
lot if you have a unique item or and
something that's a bit more expensive is
to do some education with your potential
clients around why it's so expensive
like I think people would be like oh my
god that clock cost five thousand
dollars or whatever I'll be like holy
crab you know what's it you know what I
mean kind of thing but if you work with
the client a little bit and share with
them your process and talk about what
goes into it and you kind of educate
them in that way I think that's a really
powerful way of creating those
relationships because they're like oh
okay well that's really cool it is worth
five thousand dollars do you know what
I'm saying I think there's a strong
power of association when I was in one
of my first businesses I was young and I
felt like people didn't take me
seriously and so I created a what I
called a guide to professional success
ready connected with 20 other leading
thinkers at the time 20 robbins brian
tracy huge names and i had them all
contribute an article to this free book
that i was putting out and then i can
chief did an article as well so now i
was a part of this yeah you're wearing
these other guys and so by the power of
association i was leveraging their
brands to then put some of that on me to
give myself more cred
and so if you worry about the cost what
I would try to do is think about who's
the kind of person that's buying this
who's gonna spend I don't know which is
this who's going to spend you know ten
thousand dollars on this wooden clock
yeah and then what else are they buying
and in all my pictures I would make sure
that it's set up so that I could see
some of these other elements as well you
associate the value from them so um I'm
thinking like a Porsche or expensive car
and I don't know how the claw kinda fits
into that theme or if it's in a living
room somewhere where I can see some
brand names and get the sense of oh it's
it's in that category and somebody who's
buying a Porsche is also buying one of
these clocks and so I would take amazing
pictures but take amazing pictures
leverage other brands don't just have
only your clock have these other brands
in there that have the association and
then i would put them up on on the
different social media sites yeah you're
probably your biggest lift up Instagram
but I'm like an specialty size feel like
house for example could be a really
great place to go as well because
there's a lot of designers that go on
there and they're looking for things
that are new and interesting and if you
can start to work with some designers
that could be a real great boost your
business cool yeah Facebook dark posts
might be another interesting one if
you're going after targeting designers
may be marketed designers all unhelpful
customers if you know they're in trick
is if you know people who buy from you
also by coach bag or by prada shoes or
whatever then you could target those
people who like those brands yeah yeah I
showed them your information um Kamal
how do I get my business idea heard when
I'm only 14 years old yes you know what
I know a lot of work I not a lot but I
think that there are a lot of teenage
entrepreneurs out there and you know
what more power to you because you guys
are gonna rule the world I'm telling you
you are gonna rule the world and you
might as well start now right um you
know I s I mean one question to you
might be um you know can you sell your
story to your local community newspaper
or your local community radio station or
your local community cable show you know
can you get like some traditional PR in
there and get like a bigger audience
otherwise you know like just not to
bring up the Biebs or anything but like
Justin Bieber was 14 years old and he
made YouTube videos and now look where
he is do you know what I'm saying like
you can do it you have the power and
your hands you have these amazing social
media tools that allow us and give us so
much power and give us these huge
audiences like you just gotta do it no
not to sound like Nike but it's a
powerful message um I love all the young
entrepreneurs on the channel it's cool i
love it yeah i think the key is just
starting uh you know recognize that you
will suck at the start just like
anything else you're gonna be lots when
you learn a language when you try to
ride a bike when you pick up so bored
and you're gonna fail and a stock and
the advantage you have is that you have
time on your side where you can get
better and everything you put out again
figure out what is what's what is your
message what's the idea that you have
that's going to change the world instead
of putting out content relevant to it
and it'll just be okay at the start and
you may hate it but every time make it
better than it was yesterday and you'll
build audience um [ __ ] gay and maybe
maybe last question for you wrap up and
we're going long but we are going long
lots questions very good how should I
manage my accounts if I'd be breaking
content into two languages should i
create two versions for each social
media account yeah that's a tough one
that's a tough question I mean with
Facebook you can actually say that you
want your posts to be seen specifically
only by people that speak that language
so you can actually do that on facebook
you can have
page but you can target each post
towards different languages um I don't
know with Twitter ah you know with
Twitter you could just do two separate
tweets1 in Spanish and one in English uh
I don't know again it depends to how
much time you have like do you have
enough time to manage two accounts on
out like on one two accounts on Twitter
two accounts on facebook to you don't I
mean like that's a lot of work like how
you know you also have to get through
your day right yeah i would say it
depends on your audience if you my first
reaction is to have two separate
accounts because you know i think of my
experience if you're targeting someone
like me I don't want to see Spanish
language content because if I spinach I
don't want to see I'm thinking of the
there's a bank called the bdc here in
Canada and they post everything they
have in English and French because
French is our natural very special
second language and it's super annoying
like it's the same tweet that goes out
in English and then in French I don't
want to read the French one yeah and so
why don't you create a bdc France one
right and then if I'm French I'll
subscribe to that one it just makes
sense the only the only option or the
the only caveat to that is if you're
targeting people who are who are like
who speak both who like like the
spanglish you know I was in LA recently
and there's a radio station and salsa
music as I love salsa and it announcers
we're talking in half Spanish half
English going back and forth on their
sentences all of them everybody in the
station like no matter what time i did
you listen to it I was just listening to
for the salsa music as that's what I
love ya and I couldn't understand half
of what he was saying but the audience
are people who speak that same way half
in Spanish half in English maybe they're
speaking English with their friends and
spanish at home or whatever so that's
your audience then it's a smaller
audience and I would create content that
is a mix
maybe how the sentences English and half
the sentence in spanish that's a really
direct niche market like you're trying
to go bigger i would say have two
different accounts maybe even two
different types of content like does a
Oprah Winfrey quote play as well to a
Spanish audience can bank carlos slim
helu who we may not know who he is and
for most of America and Canada so um you
might want to play up the content to
meet the different audience cool well
there's still more questions coming in
but god I respect Rebecca's time Thank
You Rebecca so much for joining thank
you man I was really awesome thank you
so much and thank you guys for watching
Rebecca for people to learn more about
you where can they go um I met Rebecca
Coleman dot C eggs i'm in canada Rebecca
Cohen Darcey a is my site and I'm if you
need to get ahold of me just hit me up
on twitter i'm at rebecca coleman on
twitter awesome well thank you guys
continue you and we'll see you soon